in the impoverished settlements that
ring the city of Johannesburg people
wait at 2:00 a.m. to make an important
decision they need to pick a queue then
wait and wait to see if anyone delivers
any food South Africa has passed the
midpoint in a five-week lockdown and in
communities like deep Sloot it's really
starting to hurt the vast majority here
have lost their jobs because they need
to survive outside the community center
residents spent 14 hours in line waiting
for food parcels that didn't turn up and
we could see the anger build many hold
the country's president Cyril Ramaphosa
responsible
[Applause]
the anger the discontent has turned into
violence and widespread looting as
people waiting for aid take matters into
their own hands
dozens of shops and supermarkets have
been broken into over the last week in
deeps loot
we found a community group with 800 bags
of vegetables to distribute and the
operation ran smoothly in their compound
outside however it was more like chaos
the queue stretched for a kilometre and
there was no social distancing in sight
eventually the organizers shut the front
gate hundreds of people here standing
outside but there's no food left in here
and one of the workers has just told me
that they cannot open this gate or they
will experience a stampede something he
says none of us would want a witness
there's quite volatile
but the residents weren't giving up and
some were clearly desperate no I just
need what's up cause we're long in this
life and I just need water to drink
we caught up with the man in charge of
our distribution we got the food today
we are still hustling out our partners
our sponsors to say guys the need is
still there we need to keep going
because the food insecurity is really
this yes it tells you that the need is
enormous I have to do it the ache of an
empty stomach takes priority over
everything else including the corona
virus pandemic that's something
residents will deal with when they have
to John sparks Sky News in deeps loot